bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur ert france pour en discuter
alors on l'a vu les négociations entre
londres et bruxelles sont toujours
bloqués à l'issue d'une septième session
de négociations sur la relation poste
bray exit les deux parties arriveront
elles à s'entendre un jour c'est une
bonne question effectivement on voit que
déjà la sortie du break site a été très
longue
vous avez bien dit une septième
conférence on a encore c'est une période
de transition où effectivement durant
cette période il ya des négociations on
voit qu'elles sont en lice on voit que
chacun défend son point de vue est
aujourd'hui encore une fois cela n'a
abouti à rien alors on va effectivement
vers nom accor 1 odile c'était déjà dans
l'est dans les tuyaux et effectivement
je pense qu'on va arriver vers vers ce
schéma moi ce qui me fait peur c'est que
la filière pêche qui est donc en stand
by depuis depuis depuis un an est une
filière déjà qui est très affaibli
justement on va on va en parler avec
vous virginie seront les deux sujets les
plus explosifs sans être semblent être
les conditions de concurrence équitables
et celui de la pêche
quelles sont les difficultés de ces deux
thèmes concrètement c'est que pour
l'instant c'est une paire de transition
comme je les dis c'est en période de
stand-by donc ça n'avance pas donc enfin
il ya un maintien des accords antérieurs
mais on voit que ce blocage la bave
devant va devoir donc réorganiser les
filières surtout la pêche et en même
temps on apprend ce jour qu'il ya un
accord qui a été négocié entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis qui va
ouvrir le marché du homard sur les
marchés européens donc là évidemment ça
va avoir un impact direct sur nos
producteurs bretons on a aussi du homard
en bretagne et ça va on en n'est pas
qu'économique et on voit bien donc
effectivement que que les chiliens
économies parce qu'effectivement c'est
le plus important aussi c'est le marché
c'est le pouvoir continuer à sauver nos
emplois qui va être impactée alors un
accord doit être trouvé au plus tard fin
octobre le temps des ratifications avant
avant la fin de période de transition
pour avoir un deal en place le 1er
janvier 1 2021 est ce que cela est
encore possible
tout est possible mais je pense que tout
le monde joue la montre je pense aussi
qu'ils on pourra aussi il était prévu un
report jusqu'en 2022 donc temps que donc
ça fonctionne comme ça en perte de
transitoire où il ya le maintien des
règles ça va continuer sous cet angle ça
permettra encore une fois de jouer sur
l'un ou sur l'autre
des désaccords mais on voit bien que
l'union européenne n'a aucun n'a aucun
pouvoir encore une fois et et le voit
bien c'est en lisant à permet de montrer
encore une fois que qu'on est dépendant
de 2,2 d'intérêt plutôt souverain et
c'est une bonne chose pour le royaume
uni mais c'est une mauvaise chose pour
l'union européenne
si aucun accord n'a été trouvé d'ici là
quels sont les différents scénarios
possibles selon vous comme vous l'avez
dit c'est donc les règles de l'om sait
qu'ils vont s'appliquer donc avec comme
dans d'autres pays comme d'autres forces
comme les etats-unis ou la chine où on
appliquera ces règles qui qui fonctionne
aussi maintenant faudra s'adapter à ce
nouveau schéma et c'est pour cela que
les transactions commerciales ne
fonctionneront pas leur nouveau schéma
on devra remettre ce qui est bien est la
bonne chose c'est peut-être l'union
douanière dont devra renforcer
effectivement nous notre nos postes aux
frontières remettre en place et a
coordonné ce schéma avec les douanes qui
est aussi permettra une nouvelle
économie
le royaume-uni accuse l'union européenne
union européenne de rendre des
négociations difficiles est ce que c'est
c'est vrai selon vous pourquoi dans
toute négociation on essaie de tirer la
couverture sur soi et donc on essaie de
faire passer l'autre pour un nouveau
mauvais négociateur pouvoir en tirer le
meilleur donc ça fait partie des
négociations je pense que monsieur
barnier de 200 points de vue a fait les
choses mais de l'autre côté évidemment
le royaume uni
il défend ses intérêts et toute la
démarche une négociation commerciale
puisque on est vraiment dans la tma
choix commercial économique s'était
c'est le nerf de la guerre l'argent donc
forcément on est dans des transactions
on est dans deux dans le le temps aussi
où on fait on prend du temps pour pour
faire marcher d'un côté ou de l'autre
ses intérêts virginie joron merci pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes des eurodéputés du
rassemblement national merci à vous